so now i have my two capacitor equations
the two forms of this equation one is i
in terms of of v and the other is v in
terms of i
and we're going to basically look at
this equation here and do a little
exercise with it to see how it works
i'm going to draw a little circuit here
and it's going to have a current source
and a capacitor the value of the
capacitor is 1
micro farad
and the value of our current source
we'll call it big i
and it's going to actually look like a
pulse like that
that will go from zero
to
three milliamps
and then back to zero over here
and the amount of time it takes that's
going to be
this time here is going to be
milli
seconds
and the question i want to answer is
what is
what is v of t right here
we're going to use this integral
equation to figure that out
so over here is where we're going to put
our answer
this is going to be t and this will be i
here's i
and our plot right down here will be
t
and here's v of t
we'll plot i this way on here in time
it's zero and then it goes up to some
value and then it goes
over
so it's a pulse of current
and we said that that was zero
this is three milliamps
and this is three
milliseconds
and now what we want to do is we want to
find v of t
oh one of the things we have to do we
have to make an assumption about v
naught here
and we're going to assume for our
problem here that v naught equals zero
volts and what that means is there's no
charge there's zero charge stored on
this capacitor when we start the
experiment
so now that let's look at three
different time periods let's look at the
period before the pulse during the pulse
and after the pulse
so we'll break the problem into three
parts
part one is before and we'll do that by
just looking up here
now we decided that v naught was zero
in the before state
so put a little zero there we decided
that i
i is zero
so that means that the term inside the
integral is zero
and what that means
zero plus zero
is equal to v of t
so before
the pulse before the pulse the capacitor
equation tells us
the voltage is zero
okay now let's go during the pulse let's
do the second period of time let's do
let's do during the pulse so now we have
to be a little more careful we have v
equals
one over c
integral from
now time equals zero
to time equals some time t
and what's i of what's the what's i
during the pulse well it's sitting right
here i is a constant
so we write in three milliamps
d tau
plus don't forget the starting voltage
what's our starting voltage well we look
right here and the starting voltage is
zero
plus
so now we can solve this v
equals one over c
times three milliamps comes out
times the integral
from zero to t
of d tau
and that equals
let's plug in c this time
three milliamps
divided by
1 microfarad
times
what does this evaluate to the integral
from zero to t of d tau
is just t
let's do a little bit of arithmetic here
to reduce this milliamps is 10 to the
minus 3 and microfarads is 10 to the
minus 6.
so let me move this up
we'll keep our plots on there
and what we end up with is v
equals
10 to the minus 3 10 to the minus six so
that's three times ten to the third
or three thousand
times time
and what's that
that's the equation that's the equation
of a line
and it has a slope of three thousand
what's the units here this is three
thousand
volts per second
and so i'll go over here and we'll we'll
sketch this in this is going to be a
line that's a straight ramp with a
constant slope
like that
it's going to be happening all during
this pulse
and we can ask what's this value right
here
what's that voltage right there okay
let's work that out
t
is three milliseconds
so let's plug in three milliseconds
right here so v
at three milliseconds
equals three thousand
times
three milliseconds
and that equals three times three is
nine
and
three thousand times
this is an exponent of minus three
so it's going to be nine volts so this
value right here
right there
is 9
volts
so that says the voltage on our
capacitor
during the pulse during the current
pulse rises in a straight line up to 9
volts and we got that from this integral
that we did the capacitor is integrating
the current adding up the current it's
integrating this pulse
to get an ever rising voltage
okay so now we've solved the capacitor
equation
during the pulse and let's now go back
to
let's go back now to what happens after
the pulse
and we'll do that over in the corner
over here
so now let's solve what happens now
let's solve what happens after
after the current pulse what happens to
this voltage from here on does it go
down does it go up does it go straight
sideways let's find out and let's use
our capacitor equation
to do this
so
now what we're doing is we're going to
define we're going to do a new integral
and we're going to start with
we're going to start at time equals
3 milliseconds
and what is our voltage at 3
milliseconds what's v naught so v naught
in this case
equals nine volts
that's for this period of time after
three milliseconds
and we'll
use our
equation again v is one over c
times the integral
of i of tau
d tau
plus v naught
all right so let's and it goes from
time
uh
it goes from time three milliseconds
to time
t
so time t now is is out here somewhere
on the time scale and we're we know the
voltage right here we filled it in
there's there's the voltage right there
we're going to fill that in and we're
going to work out what's the voltage out
here after three milliseconds
so to solve this integral we look and
see well what's i of tau what's i of tau
during this time let's look at our chart
the pulse is at zero
oh look so this term this whole term
right
here this entire term right here
is zero
and what is v naught v naught we decided
was right there v naught is nine volts
that's where we started from
and so the answer here after after the
pulse goes away is v
equals
9 volts
and i can sketch that in up here and
basically it just goes straight sideways
at the new
voltage so that's how we solve a
capacitor problem a really simple one
and it happens that we were integrating
a current pulse and what we got was a
voltage ramp